I am very good at hiring because I've
made a lot of mistakes I learned to look
at the specific individual and look for
the most important traits in them and
ignore everything else especially the
resume sends you in the wrong direction
I learned through trial and error what
makes a great manager what makes a great
salesperson and that's who I always hire
if you're going to hire a lot of
salespeople for your organization I
found that I look for the same three
things in every single person I hired I
wanted someone who was insecure with
something to prove if somebody walks in
they're cocky they never become your
great salespeople my top ten salespeople
making millions of dollars a year every
year came to my office in December
swearing they would never have another
good year why it was ridiculous but they
were insecure enough to think it could
never happen again you want an insecure
person if you're hiring a salesperson
with something to prove you also want
someone who has a positive attitude in
every way because you know what happens
is a positive person when they get hit
and sales is all about getting hit and
knocked down they spend very little time
feeling sorry for themselves they get
right back up they're back out you
almost need a low IQ like hit me again
hit me again hit me again that's a great
salesperson and then you need the work
ethic to go with it nobody is great and
sale unless they work like crazy so
those are the three traits I look for in
every great salesperson what I look for
in a manager is someone who's gonna be
loyal I mean heck I'm gonna build a
giant house which is my business on a
shaky foundation how far am I gonna get
I need a structure where the footing as
loyal as can be is gonna stand there
through the thick and thin I also need
someone who believes that we're gonna
succeed I need someone with the positive
attitude always a positive attitude
because you know what I find I find a
manager with a positive attitude is
always gonna find a way to get to where
you want them to go a mark of a good
manager is someone who's organized I
always ask every
I'm interviewing in an interview on a
scale of 1 to 10 how would you rate
yourself as an organized person I never
hire anyone who says 9 or 10 I want the
guy who says oh about a 12 a manager
without follow-through is useless you
got to be able to give the command they
get it done and they don't forget about
it when something distracts them a
manager always follows through